une cérémonie officielle pour marquer le
retour des sentinelles
de jeunes militaires comme gaël d'un dut
pichette qui se disent honoré d'avoir
été choisi c'est certain qu'après les
événements tragiques d'octobre dernier
c'est d'autant plus important est
honorable pour moi que de pouvoir
participer le 22 octobre une autre
sentinelles le caporal n'étonne cyril ou
a perdu la vie alors qu'ils montaient la
garde devant la tombe du soldat inconnu
il a été abattu par michael zehaf bibeau
qui a été tué après être entré au
parlement dans les jours qui ont suivi
des policiers d'ottawa s'étaient portés
volontaires pour assurer la sécurité des
sentinelles le mandat vient maintenant
de leur être officiellement confiée par
le gouvernement fédéral ont aperçu un
jeune homme brillant et abcès la raison
pour laquelle notre gouvernement a
décidé
d'avoir une protection des des policiers
provinciaux les sentinelles vont être
moins jusqu'en 2020 la coopération avec
la police justement est basé sur la
menace qui est qui et évaluer tous les
jours deux policiers a remis seront sur
place à tour de rôle après leur quart de
travail des heures supplémentaires pour
les agents qui n'ont pas hésité à
participer
avant le 22 octobre dit il personne ne
croyait que les sentinelles pouvaient
être des cibles ils sont debout sous la
pluie le froid ils ne sont pas armés
tous mes collègues sont prêts à venir
les protéger une présence rassurante
pour les parents des sentinelles ce sont
que toujours un peu de crainte là je
pense que la sécurité s'est beaucoup
améliorée une sécurité qui comme la
présence de sentinelle sera assurée de 9
heures à 17 heures pour les sept
prochains mois un programme qui se
terminera le 10 novembre la veille du
jour du souvenir ici nathalie tremblay
radio canada ottawa